Esta es la capital más contaminada de
América Latina según un informe
realizado por la compañía Suiza iq Air
en cooperación con el programa de
Naciones Unidas para el medio ambiente
situada a Santiago como la capital con
la peor calidad de aire en la región el
ranking se mide por cuantas
micropartículas
pm2,5 existen en el aire originadas de
la quema de combustibles fósiles e
incendios naturales y son comúnmente
causantes de enfermedades respiratorias
pero tienen la capacidad de poder
ingresar al tracto respiratorio y
producir cierto grado de inflamación el
hecho de que la vías respiratoria ya
estén con cierto grado de inflamación
hace que las defensas para los virus que
puedan haber en esta época circulando
disminuye por lo tanto aumenta la
posibilidad de infección respiratoria
producto de los virus un informe de la
prestigiosa revista médica de lanced
ubica a Chile como el país
latinoamericano con más mortalidad
atribuible a la contaminación del aire
con 250 muertes por cada millón de
habitantes al año el gobierno chileno ha
expresado su preocupación sobre las
complicaciones respiratorias en sus
ciudadanos Nosotros hemos estado
preocupados y ocupados del tema de la
infección con virus respiratoria hemos
estado viendo estas últimas semanas un
alto número de casos de virus
respiratorio esencial con cuadros graves
en niños menores debido a la creciente
contaminación la salud de los habitantes
de Santiago empeora cada vez más